Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
C'è qualcosa che accomuna
voi tutti che siete qui,
anche me,
quelli che ci seguono
in differita o in diretta.
È l'essere seduti: siamo tutti seduti.
Ma in realtà, sono molte
[le] cose che ci accomunano.
Una forse più di tutte,
che è all'origine di tutto,
e che è l'essere nati.
Abbiamo tutti l'esperienza
di essere figli.
Poi, molti diventano essi stessi genitori:
[ma] non tutti. Anzi, sempre di meno.
Perché?
Come mai?
Cosa sta alla base
della scelta, o non scelta,
di avere figli,
e quali le implicazioni?
È una scelta personale,
ma è anche una scelta di coppia.
E come vedremo,
è anche una scelta collettiva.
È una scelta del presente,
ma che va molto oltre il presente.
E anche le conseguenze del farla
o non farla questa scelta,
hanno ricadute per i singoli,
ma anche per la collettività
più in generale.
È un po' come il voto.
Io posso pensare che
il mio singolo voto sia irrilevante:
anche se mi astenessi,
alle prossime elezioni, cosa cambierebbe?
Non cambia di fatto nulla.
Ma se tutti si astenessero?
Se tutti si astenessero,
salterebbe la democrazia.
E un po' vale anche per la demografia.
Supponiamo che, 50 anni fa,
si fosse smesso in tutto il mondo,
per qualsiasi motivo, di produrre sedie.
Quali sarebbero le conseguenze?
Staremmo un po' meno comodi:
voi magari seduti per terra, io in piedi.
Questo però vale per qualsiasi bene
prodotto dall'uomo o dalla donna.
Se venisse a mancare anche del tutto,
tutto sommato potremmo cavarcela.
Anche per i beni e i prodotti
che ormai consideriamo
quasi indispensabili:
ad esempio, se mancasse il cellulare,
di colpo, faremmo una tragedia.
Come faremmo, senza cellulare?
Vabbè, in qualche modo
ce la caveremmo comunque.
Possiamo sopravvivere
anche senza cellulare.
Ma c'è un bene
che ha una particolare
importanza strategica,
e sono i figli, sono le nuove generazioni.
Se 50 anni fa si fosse smesso,
in tutto il mondo, per qualsiasi motivo,
di produrre figli,
quali sarebbero le conseguenze?
Le donne più giovani
avrebbero più di 50 anni,
quindi ormai oltre
la loro vita riproduttiva.
L'ultima generazione
sarebbe la mia, sostanzialmente.
E quindi, oltre la possibilità
di riprodursi, e avere figli;
e quindi, saremmo
irreversibilmente avviati
verso la fine di questa incredibile,
mirabolante, strana storia dell'umanità.
Allora a questo punto,
qualsiasi altro bene prodotto
diventerebbe di colpo irrilevante.
La produzione scientifica,
la produzione letteraria,
la produzione culturale,
sarebbe tutto avviato su un binario morto.
Chi scriverebbe libri,
sapendo che nessuno più,
poi, potrebbe leggerli?
Ma prima ancora dell'estinzione,
la società stessa smetterebbe
progressivamente di funzionare,
perché avremmo sempre di più
persone in età anziana,
e sempre più anziane,
sempre meno persone al centro
della vita attiva lavorativa,
e quindi, anche,
meno persone che finanziano,
e fanno funzionare, qualsiasi servizio.
Ad esempio, negli ospedali
sempre meno medici e infermieri:
quindi sempre meno ospedali.
Anche i trasporti pubblici:
ne avremo sempre di meno,
dovremmo ridurli sempre di più.
Le poste.
Le pensioni.
Chi pagherebbe le pensioni?
Quindi, progressivamente,
un aumento della povertà,
un aumento delle disuguaglianze,
una crescita delle tensioni sociali:
aumenterebbe l'instabilità politica.
Però, per arrivare
a uno scenario di questo tipo,
in realtà non c'è bisogno che di colpo
si smetta di avere figli.
Basta anche lasciare che la fecondità
rimanga su livelli molto bassi.
Perché quando rimane persistentemente
su livelli molto bassi,
si entra in una trappola,
che poi forza sempre di più
la curva demografica
a diventare negativa.
C'è un livello di equilibrio
tra generazioni,
che è questo valore di due figli
in media per donna,
che corrispondono sostanzialmente
a due figli per coppia.
E se si mantiene questo livello,
la popolazione non cresce
e non diminuisce,
e le nuove generazioni
hanno, sostanzialmente,
la consistenza delle
generazioni dei genitori.
Già oggi, nel mondo in cui viviamo,
la maggioranza dei paesi
è sotto questo livello,
è sotto il livello
di equilibrio generazionale.
La maggioranza dei paesi.
Poi ci sono alcuni paesi, come l'Italia,
che si trovano su livelli molto più bassi,
più vicina a un figlio, in media,
per donna che a due.
Questo porta a squilibri demografici
che vanno ad autoalimentarsi,
e vanno a vincolare progressivamente
ogni nuova generazione verso il basso.
Le minori nascite passate
diventano minori genitori oggi;
meno genitori oggi
portano a meno nascite domani;
meno nascite domani
portano a meno genitori dopodomani;
quindi, di fatto diventa irreversibile
questo avvitamento continuo
delle nascite verso il basso.
Noi dobbiamo pensare
che la popolazione non è
un'entità astratta.
La popolazione è fatta di storie di vita,
di storie di vita
che sono in relazione tra di loro,
e che sono in continua tensione
con le sfide del proprio tempo.
Quindi dobbiamo pensare alla popolazione,
possiamo pensare alla popolazione
come un grande libro, un grande libro
che contiene queste storie.
E ogni generazione scrive
il proprio capitolo in questo libro,
la propria storia, le proprie vicende.
E prima di chiudere il proprio capitolo,
predispone le pagine bianche
su cui la generazione successiva
andrà a raccontare le proprie vicende.
Per gran parte della storia dell'umanità,
queste pagine si sono aggiunte
in modo del tutto naturale,
spontaneo e scontato,
perché la condizione comune
era quella di mettersi assieme:
si formava un'unione di coppia,
poi semplicemente i figli arrivavano.
E ne arrivavano quanti ne arrivavano.
Oggi, non è più così.
Da qualche generazione,
siamo entrati nell'era della scelta
di quanti figli avere e quando averli.
E alla domanda di meno figli
è corrisposto poi lo sviluppo
di un'offerta di strumenti
per, in maniera efficiente,
limitare le nascite,
che è appunto la contraccezione moderna.
Questa è la fase
in cui la scelta da esercitare
è stata quella della riduzione,
quindi da cinque figli
a quattro, a tre, a due,
Poi, due figli è diventato
un po' il punto di riferimento,
il numero ideale,
il numero medio desiderato di figli
nelle società moderne avanzate.
In realtà, si è andati
ulteriormente sotto questo due figli,
questa soglia dei due figli;
e questo è avvenuto in concomitanza
con l'entrata in una ulteriore fase,
del tutto inedita,
nella storia dell'umanità.
Se in passato una donna,
come condizione di base, era feconda,
e la contraccezione interveniva
in maniera mirata
per limitare le nascite
che altrimenti sarebbero state
naturalmente più elevate,
da poche generazioni
questa situazione si è ribaltata.
Quindi la condizione comune di base,
per una donna, è non essere feconda,
di avere una copertura
continua contraccettiva.
Che poi viene sospesa,
se si decide di avere figli.
Quindi la scelta di avere un figlio,
oltre ad essere una scelta non scontata,
è diventata una scelta non da fare
in riduzione, ma in aggiunta.
Questo vuol dire, di fatto,
che se, in passato, non scegliere
equivaleva ad accettare
la condizione di avere figli,
oggi, invece, non scegliere
lascia nella condizione
di non aver nessun figlio.
In questa nuova fase,
il numero di figli è sceso
sotto il numero desiderato.
Come mai non riusciamo a realizzare
le scelte desiderate?
Il fatto è che viviamo in un mondo
che è molto più complesso,
in continuo cambiamento
rispetto al passato,
quindi il futuro è diventato
molto più incerto.
È cresciuta enormemente
l'incertezza nei confronti del futuro.
La scelta di avere un figlio...
è diventato l'indicatore
più sensibile alla combinazione
tra le condizioni oggettive del presente
e le aspettative nei confronti del futuro.
Quando queste due cose
si uniscono positivamente,
allora la scelta, non scontata,
di aggiungere vita alla propria vita
più facilmente può essere realizzata.
Dove, invece, all'incertezza
nei confronti del futuro
si unisce la difficoltà
oggettiva del presente,
e la mancanza poi di politiche
pubbliche adeguate,
cioè: mancano i servizi per l'infanzia;
non ci sono strumenti adeguati
di conciliazione tra lavoro e famiglia;
è complicata l'organizzazione
della vita familiare;
è alto il rischio di povertà
delle coppie con figli,
allora cosa succede?
Che questa scelta, pur desiderata,
semplicemente rimane in sospeso.
Rimane in sospeso:
ma intanto, il tempo passa.
E implicitamente, diventa una rinuncia.
Detto in altri termini,
se oggi un paese moderno e avanzato
volesse ridurre le nascite,
non è che ha bisogno di disincentivare
i propri cittadini ad avere figli.
Basta semplicemente che non metta in campo
politiche adeguate
di sostegno alla natalità.
Paesi come Svezia, Francia,
Germania più recentemente,
che hanno una fecondità maggiore
rispetto alla media europea,
hanno un'attenzione continua
rispetto agli strumenti
che aiutano poi le coppie
a realizzare le proprie scelte.
E non solo:
a mettere in relazione
la scelta di avere figli
con il percorso
professionale e lavorativo,
con la realizzazione personale.
Tutto questo, in generale, è parte
di un investimento collettivo,
che si fa sulle nuove generazioni.
Queste sono politiche
che hanno, come base culturale,
l'idea che avere un figlio,
l'arrivo di un figlio,
non sia solo un costo privato
a carico dei genitori,
ma che sia un bene collettivo,
su cui tutta la società
ha convenienza a investire.
Perché poi, con un rinnovo
generazionale solido
si rafforza il futuro di tutto il paese.
Quindi, avere un figlio
è la scelta che più impegna positivamente
il presente nei confronti del futuro.
Quindi, questo significa
che la difficoltà
a realizzare questa scelta,
al di là delle conseguenze,
che sono gli squilibri demografici,
la difficoltà di sostenibilità sociale,
la difficoltà di mantenere
la spesa sanitaria o previdenziale,
ma questa difficoltà diventa poi
l'elemento, l'indicatore
che maggiormente riesce a rivelare
la difficoltà di un paese
di mettere in relazione positiva
le scelte individuali
con il benessere collettivo.
La scelta di avere un figlio
è l'indicatore, possiamo dire così,
che maggiormente ci aiuta a capire
se stiamo andando nella direzione giusta.
Se è la rotta giusta,
quella appunto che stiamo seguendo,
all'interno di una mappa che ha due assi.
Un asse è quello della capacità
di trasformare i desideri individuali
in valore collettivo.
L'altro asse è la capacità
di mettere in connessione solida
il presente e il futuro.
Ma prima di tutto,
è una scelta.
È una scelta libera.
Siamo liberi, individualmente,
di non avere figli, adottati o biologici;
non c'è nessuna legge della natura
che ci obblighi ad averli;
come non c'è, d'altronde,
nessuna legge della natura
che garantisca che il genere umano
abbia una sua continuità nel tempo,
generazione dopo generazione.
C'è solo il significato che noi possiamo,
individualmente e collettivamente,
dare al nostro essere nel mondo,
e c'è solo il valore
che noi decidiamo di generare
nel nostro agire nel mondo.
Però siamo liberi.
Siamo liberi di stare in piedi
o di stare seduti.
Siamo liberi di avere o non avere figli.
Evitiamo, però, che il nostro futuro
sia deciso dalle nostre non scelte.
Grazie.
(Applausi)